because i heard you can potentially get  a sex offense  that's the same reason why i don't i  don't like piss in public i heard you  get from peens yeah you get it from that  too they want to be like 10. don't stop  here you people you put on the road [ __ ]  yes  yep  i didn't know that was gonna be the one  that set him off hold on what do you  mean i was peeing you're being  [Laughter]  wait why are you peeing in public [ __ ]  the [ __ ] we were on an rv road trip  right and then that's cute and then i  think she got out to pee isn't there a  toilet in the rv there is i knew that  was  so there was right but it's one of those  that you like you put on the hitch so  everything's locked up it's not like one  of those that's attached there's a hitch  you see  [Laughter]  my plans  i didn't know bart was gonna get that  offended for this